[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
actor danny masterson pleads not guilty
to rape charges
and please search a connecticut property
for possible clues in the disappearance
of a mother of five
our main goal is to again work towards
providing
the family of jennifer doulos some
closure plus a texas motel pool death
mystery
is one step closer to being solved
thanks to dna testing
we are very pleased after 55 years to be
able to identify our jane doe
is jolane hemi and a judd sets a trial
date for the only former officer charged
in the brianna taylor case
why defense attorneys want it moved to
another county
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
actor danny masterson entered a not
guilty plea on charges of raping three
women in los angeles county
masterson is accused of sexually
assaulting the women in his hollywood
hills home between 2001
and 2003. the actor is best known for
his role in that 70s show
masterson is also facing a civil lawsuit
along with the church of scientology
accusing them of harassing the women for
coming forward masterson is out on more
than three million dollars bond
and did not appear in court his attorney
was there on his behalf
and insisted he's not guilty the case is
now being handed over
to a trial judge the earner we'd like to
put this case out as much as possible
we're
lacking a lot of discovery we can't
prepare for any
preliminary hearing without much more
discovery
and we've got coveted so we're looking
to put this out as long as we can
we didn't have a discussion off the
record with respect to potential
scheduling
i advise all council that i'm just
simply going to sign the matter that you
can discuss further dates
now that mr master has been remaining
joining me for legal analysis is
criminal defense attorney gigi gonzalez
and co-host terry austin
gigi simple arraignment of the charges
lawyers says not guilty as expected
what should we expect as this case
continues though
yeah so he's pleading not guilty he's
going to demand all of the discovery and
information as well as a speedy trial
uh from here on out we can expect
depositions to occur we can expect
uh certain evidentiary emotions filed
um maybe even a motion to dismiss later
down the line
um but until then uh we'll just watch
the child play uh the case play out
from here now terry gg kind of touched
on it motions are bound to be filed what
kind of motions do you expect
in a case like this well you know beyond
the motion to change the venue
or as gg said a motion to dismiss which
is usual
i think we might see emotion evidence of
prior
bad acts you know there have been
allegations that masterson
sexually assaulted at least two others
and we will probably see
a motion by the defense to exclude that
evidence and you know
any evidence of a prior bad act is only
admissible if in fact it shows
intent or pattern and so i think we
might
very well see something like that to
exclude it yeah it can be kind of
similar to what happened in bill cosby's
second case
uh where they had those women who are
uncharged bad actors testifying thank
you both
and now to connecticut where police are
continuing to look for the remains of a
mother missing
for a year and a half law and crimes
rachel stockman was on the scene and has
the latest
on the search for jennifer doulos we are
outside a home in farmington connecticut
where state
police have been here all day searching
this home you can see one of the
vehicles
owned by state police leaving right now
they've been out here all day searching
for clues
in relation to the disappearance of mom
jennifer doulos you'll remember this
case she was the mom of five children
who disappeared after dropping her
children off in new canaan connecticut
a little bit later police became
suspicious and then
arrested her husband fotus dulos
and his then girlfriend michelle
trocconis
fotus dulles later committed suicide and
they've been trying to locate the body
of jennifer doulos
ever since it's discussed in restaurants
and in shopping
shopping stores and supermarkets we
really don't know what to believe
because mr doodles maintain his
innocence until his suicide
i think closure first for the family of
the dulos family of course
i'm quite sure that the populace of both
all three towns west hartford and
farmington and avon
would like to see justice carried out
appropriately for mrs dulos
we've had a drone up over this house and
this house
used to be owned by fotus duelist's
company
and we're hearing that it is in some
kind of real estate transaction and that
transaction may be closing soon
so it seems that state police wanted to
come back out here to see if they could
find
any more clues before that real estate
transaction went through
this investigation is still active and
ongoing
at this point we don't do not have any
updates to provide to the public
we've seen police come and go walk the
perimeter and we've even seen them dig
in a couple of sites in the backyard
here
i do not believe they found anything but
we're continuing to monitor this
situation
very closely and if we get any new
developments we will let you know
now gigi we see that movement there at
the house that was owned by photos
dulles
company could it be because the fact
that it's changing hands to someone else
that's why we're getting this added
activity
exactly right and they've already
searched this property they haven't been
able to find clues in the past
i don't believe they're going to find
any new clues now
but because they uh it's about to be uh
going to a new owner they're going to
search the property to make sure that
they covered
every inch of it to ensure they didn't
miss any clues
terry at this point a year and a half
into jennifer doulos missing
i think many people are thinking we're
going to find a body and not a person
how hopeful
are you that we're going to find these
remains you know i think if we find the
remains it's not
going to be in good condition technology
is what
led us to this particular property
because his phone
was actually traced you know dulos's
phone was traced to that property
and apparently he was there for a couple
of hours in the afternoon of the day
that she
went missing so hopefully they will find
if not
all of her remains at least some
evidence of her body being placed there
yeah at this point really i think
justice if it can be found
is in the closure and just the knowing
of where jennifer delos
is for her family and of course for the
community thank you terry
thank you gigi still ahead on law and
crime daily presidential pardons by the
dozen
why rapper little wayne will avoid a
prison sentence but the tiger king
is left hanging an exclusive interview
with a pardon attorney
[Music]
next
[Music]
before leaving office president trump
issued 73 pardons and commuted the
sentences
of an additional 70 people
rapper little wayne whose real name is
dwayne michael carter jr
was granted a pardon carter pled guilty
to possessing a firearm by a convicted
felon and faced a 10-year sentence
also making the list rapper kodak black
whose legal name is bill carpe
trump commuted his nearly four-year
sentence for making a false statement on
a federal document
while attempting to buy firearms he has
served about half of his sentence
the rappers are waiting in trial in
south carolina for charges of criminal
sexual conduct
not on the list tiger king joe exotic
the netflix star has been vocal about
his request to be pardoned for violating
federal wildlife charges and a
murder-for-hire plot
of his rival carol baskin it appears his
plea was denied
a federal judge is cracking down on
another of the tiger king's rivals
jeff lowe lowe took over exotic's animal
park
and is now being ordered to surrender
all big cats under the age of one year
and their mothers he's accused of
mistreating the animals and is facing a
lawsuit filed by the department of
justice
the trump administration carried out its
13th and final federal execution
dustin higgs was convicted of killing
three women in maryland in 1996.
he died by lethal injection early
saturday morning also executed
was corey johnson who was convicted of
killing seven people in richmond
virginia
the justice department resumed federal
executions last year following a 17-year
hiatus carrying out more than
any other president in 120 years
joining me now is attorney tammy allison
aka the pardon
attorney tammy is the founder and expert
of the first minority owned
federal executive clemency law firm it's
truly an honor to have you on tammy
thank you for joining us
thank you so much for having me now
danny first question
because i know for many of us pardons
and and the like this is the first time
we're really hearing it
the president basically has the part the
power sorry to pardon and commute
sentences federally
without any kind of restriction right
facts
yes you are absolutely correct uh it's
in the constitution
article two section 2 clause 1. that's
what people refer to as pardon powers
now what that means is for an individual
that has been conv convicted of a
federal
crime they are able to request
forgiveness that's what the clemency is
now with clemency there are two
different types there's a commutation
and then there's a pardon
a commutation is for an individual that
is currently serving a sentence at the
federal bureau's prisons
that individual is able to request to be
released early
or for their fines or restitution to be
reduced
or both if an individual has not been
sentenced
to a federal institution they would be
requesting
a commutation as well but if they had
maybe supervised release or probation
they could request to have their final
restitution
reduced or removed now on the other hand
with the presidential pardon
which is commonly incorrectly used
interchangeably with clemency
a pardon is when an individual has a
federal conviction
five years after the date of their
conviction or the date of sentencing
if they were not sentenced to
incarceration
they are able to request that same
forgiveness
through a presidential pardon now the
president
can pardon someone
without going through the department of
justice's office of the pardon attorney
same with the commutations traditionally
most of the applicants for
federal executive clemency go through
the united states department of
justice's
office of the pardon attorney the
attorneys in that office they review
those petitions
they make a recommendation to the
president
as as to whether the petition should be
granted favorably or
denied the president can listen to those
attorneys in the office
or not because again he has those
constitutional powers
to grant or deny clemency he also has
the ability
not to even go through the office of the
pardon attorney
and do what we saw today with his final
list of pardons that came out including
the rapper lil wayne tell me
let's kind of talk about that list we've
got lil wayne steve bannon
you've got sarita steve martin you've
got a people who run the gamut of
different backgrounds but when we talked
during the break you said
nothing surprised you about what was in
the the list of pardons but what was not
in them what do you mean by that
i was actually surprised not to see
president trump's name listed i had
thought that he would probably go ahead
and test the limits of the constitution
and its pardoned powers the fact that it
has never been done before
but we have seen preemptive pardons in
the past one of the most famous being
president nixon um in that situation he
did
resign and then the vice president
pardoned him but there is nothing that
could stop
a president or anyone in the future
another president from doing a
preemptive self-pardon
so i was definitely surprised now i've
heard some commentators and other legal
analysts
suggest that perhaps he could have
pardoned himself
but kept it a secret but given what
we've seen with his characteristics
i don't think that he would keep it a
secret if in fact he did do
a preemptive self-pardon now tell me a
quick question because i
as i look through some of them some
people long list as to why he pardoned
them supported by
x y and z person some people just
nothing like stephen bannon
does that make sense to you it does
again
the constitution this man he's the
president whoever voted
him in there they put him in there and
with that seat and that title of being
the president
of the united states of america he can
do whatever he wants to do
under the constitution so nothing is
surprising to me
um i understand that me having been at
that office
since 2008 as an intern and then
i spent five years of my career in that
office under the bush obama and trump
administrations
i understand that the general public
doesn't see it as
easily as i see it but it's not
surprising
it's just kind of how it goes i guess
well yes or no tammy unfortunately i'm
sorry we've got to go i apologize i i
wish we had more time to talk but we'll
talk to you next time and thank you
again for all the information
coming up on law and crime daily the
latest move to the deadly trial
of one of the ex-cops charged in the
george floyd case
plus why dna has answered some questions
in a texas cold case but also created
new ones
part of a 55 year old cold case in texas
has been solved thanks to dna
but the case is far from closed angela
levy tells us why it's still
a mystery investigators know that jolane
hemi drowned in a swimming pool in july
of 1966.
what they don't know is whether or not
her death was an accident
or a homicide we are very pleased
after 55 years to be able to identify
our jane doe is
jolane hammy for decades jolane hemi was
only known as
unknown ex-girl in pecos texas on july
5th
1966 the 17 year old drowned in a motel
swimming pool
she was there with a man who went to the
front desk asking for his registration
card
claiming he needed it as identification
to go to the hospital
but he never showed a facial
reconstruction was conducted which
yielded no clues
but last year jolane was exhumed dna was
collected and testing linked through
genealogy
revealed her true identity and talking
to the family
last week was like talking to him 50
years ago
the emotion was just as raw and just as
solid
of their missing family member we stand
here today
having accomplished the sole purpose of
innovative forensic which is providing
answers to families
it's been a sad story but it's also
with uh we feel a happy ending uh
so we can bring her home and and
have a closure on what happened to her
we
always were afraid that you know
something happened to her and
of course never knowing what
was always kind of a bad deal jolene
hemi's sister told detectives that there
was a man who was interested
in her who kept stopping by the
restaurant where they worked in kansas
city
his name may have been joe investigators
are also eager to determine the name of
the man
who was with joe lane at the motel that
day and they are optimistic that they
can do it
for law and crime daily i'm angenette
levy
an iowa farmer is hoping for a second
chance in civil court after his win
in criminal court law and crime chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
has the latest on the father verse son
saga
thanks brian coming up this week i'm
brian ross investigates the story of a
family tragedy in iowa
the iowa supreme court this week will
hear the case of jason carter
who was accused by his father bill
carter of killing his mother
shirley carter jason carter was found
not guilty in a criminal trial
but he was found guilty in a civil trial
now his lawyers will ask for a new trial
from the iowa supreme court
i talked with jason carter and his wife
shelly about what they expect and what
they want
uh we're hoping that uh they'll either
they'll either throw it out
or at least overturn the the ruling
for the civil and give us a new trial
you know our main hopes are just to have
it thrown out all together but
at the least get a new trial that's
coming up this week on brian ross
investigates on the long crime trial
network brian
thanks brian when we come back a hearing
for the ex-cop charge in the brianna
taylor case
we break down the defense's motion after
the break
prosecutors in the george floyd case are
trying yet again to delay the trial
of one of the former officers charged
with murder
the trial for derek shogun is scheduled
to begin in march a minnesota judge
ordered children be tried separately and
before the three other ex-cops
prosecutors are asking the judge to
reconsider that decision
citing health concerns during the coven
19 pandemic
and are asking for the trials to be
rejoined shoving is also facing tax
evasion charges
that trial has been delayed until june
30th
and in kentucky defense attorneys for
the former detective charge in the
brianna taylor case
are seeking to move his trial brett
hankinson is facing three felony charges
of wanton endangerment for shooting into
a nearby apartment during a raid on
taylor's home last march
no one is charged with taylor's death a
hearing on the motion for a change of
venue is scheduled for march 25th
hankinson's attorney appeared at a
remote hearing via phone
on his behalf and said he plans to file
the motion in about two weeks
i don't have a specific county but i
believe that the statute says it should
be
an adjacent county unless that
is not feasible also and then i assume
any county in the state
is is open i'd love to have it up here
in northern kentucky
well i can understand why you would
prefer that mr matthews
when i was a trial attorney i had a case
that was
the venue was changed now we did not go
to an adjacent county
because of media coverage that you know
would have affected
adjacent counties to jefferson and we
ended up trying the case
in boyle county in the danville
circuit court that gives me some idea of
where you're
thinking aside from possible change in
venue
both sides indicated they're ready for
trial the judge scheduled to begin
on august 31st the discovery has been
provided i don't have any questions
about it and i don't think there are any
um outstanding procedural issues at this
point
and venezuela could you possibly if you
could give me an idea
of how long you think the prosecution's
case would take to try
excluding jury selection i would
anticipate
three to four days for the
commonwealth's case
all right august 31st uh 10 o'clock
to start the jury trial
my panel is back with me for a legal
analysis gg what do you make of this
argument that there should be a change
of venue
is it strategy or is it something else
it's definitely strategy
and for hankerson to succeed on it he's
going to have to show
that he is not likely to get a fair
trial in louisville
due to the massive media attention the
death of brianna taylor
has consistently gotten since early last
year it's going to be really difficult
to find a jury
anywhere that hasn't formed some kind of
opinion on this case
so he's got an uphill battle about uh
getting a
change of venue here and terry we heard
it could be a potentially very short
trial what do you think that trial looks
like and could it spark
more questions as to why no one's being
charged for brianna taylor's death
i do think it will be a short trial it's
only one officer i think they're going
to argue that hankinson was under the
belief
that the information and the search
warrant was accurate and that he
was acting reasonably under the
circumstances
and shooting into the apartment was not
unreasonable
gg terry thank you very much and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you